- Hi, I'm Jen.
- And I'm Nikki.
Today, we're discussing the
untold stories of queer people
throughout history because
they definitely exist.
Jen has a pipe, and we have a gavel,
so what could possibly go wrong?
(upbeat music)
Today, we are talking about
the American Treasurer,
Eleanor Roosevelt, who is
who is rumored to have had
relationships with both men and women.
Lots of rumors, lots of stories.
We're going to get into it today.
What do you know about her?
- I know she is married
to Theodore Roosevelt.
(laughs)
- No she wasn't.
- Oh, she wasn't?
Who's she married to?
- The other Roosevelt, Franklin.
- Oh, Frankie Boy.
- Okay, Eleanor Roosevelt
was born on October 11, 1884
to a wealthy family in New York City.
Unfortunately, by age
10, everyone was dead.
So she like went to live
with other relatives,
and like, the brother who lived.
In 1903, Eleanor got engaged
to Franklin Roosevelt,
her fifth cousin once removed.
- Do you think they kissed
with tongue back then?
- Absolutely.
After they married,
Franklin's political career
really started ramping up,
so this is where things get
a little bit scandalous, okay.
So, Franklin ended up cheating on Eleanor,
with Eleanor's secretary,
which is pretty shitty
because Eleanor's secretary
is probably somebody who
is pretty close to her,
knew what her schedule was,
knew where she was at all the
time, and then was just like,
"Alright cool, she's busy,
let me go fuck her husband real quick."
- Also, he wasn't hot.
You're really going to risk
your career for someone,
it's like, I hope they're
hot and like, not racist.
He didn't check either one of those boxes.
- So Eleanor first found out
about this, she was like,
"Fuck this, lets get divorced,"
'cause she was not down
for it, but as you know,
divorce when you're in
the political limelight,
like, that's bad, it
could end your career,
you have bad press, people
think differently of you.
So Franklin was like, "Look,
I promise to end the affair,
if you stay with me."
And she was like, "Fine,"
but pretty much after that,
their marriage was never the same.
When Franklin took office
in 1933, as the President,
Eleanor kept doing her own damn thing
as First Lady of the United States.
She was very politically
active, and she started a weekly
press conference for just
female journalists who were
typically not allowed in
other press conferences.
Again, just surrounding
herself with ladies.
Okay, now is where we
get to the gay stuff.
It is both juicy and steamy.
Eleanor's biographer
and many others believe
the First Lady was in a
relationship with one Lorena Hickok.
So Lorena Hickok is a
reporter, nicknamed Hick,
was said to have ate, drank,
smoked, gambled, and swore.
Sounds like a classic butch lesbian to me.
- [Jen] Yeah, she sounds fun.
- So although Hick and
Eleanor knew each other
for a few years, it wasn't
until Hick was assigned
to cover Eleanor during
Franklin's presidential campaign
in 1932 that they really
got to know each other.
When Hick wasn't on the road for her job,
she actually lived out of the White House,
and she gave Eleanor a ring
that Eleanor would wear publicly.
- That sounds gay.
- The fact that Hick
lived in the White House
and gave her a ring, and no
one thought anything of it,
no one was ever like,
"Oh I wonder if those two
are just like, fucking each other."
- I think that speaks to
heterosexism because they were
just like, "it's unfathomable
- Gal pals, gal pals.
- that two women could find a relationship
and have pleasure from it.
- Anyways, so when Hick and
Eleanor weren't together,
they were writing each other letters,
and that's where we have proof.
The two of them exchanged
more than 3,300 letters
between 1932 and shortly
before Eleanor died.
Like why would you do that
if you weren't like kind
of obsessed with somebody?
- I don't know.
What did you ask me?
(laughs)
So these letters they were exchanging,
are they romantic in nature?
- Oh yes.
- Oh, okay.
- Would you like to read some?
- Okay.
- We're going to read some.
Picture this, Eleanor in her
nightie, pondering to the moon.
Her snoring president of a husband
she doesn't sleep with anymore,
snoring in the next room.
She saunters to her desk,
and pulls out a quill.
Were they, I don't think they
were using quills back then.
- They would have had pens.
- Probably using pens,
okay, this is what she says.
"Even though I am busy every minute."
- God damn.
- That's saucy.
You wouldn't just say that to somebody
you weren't like, hmm, you know.
- No you wouldn't.
That's not something you send to a friend.
A little uncomfortable
hearing you read that,
that's how uncommon it is.
- Now we cut to Hick, out on
the lonely road as a reporter.
Nothing can keep her company
at night but her cigarettes
and her distant memory of Eleanor's lips.
Here, you read this part.
- "Most clearly," I
don't know, that voice.
"I wonder what we'll do when
we meet, what we'll say."
What is northeast corner? Here?
What if this is just Hick
revealing she is the worst kisser
in the world, just kisses
right here every time?
- I only like this part.
It gets better.
- It gets better?
- There's more.
"Oh, how I wanted to
put my arms around you
in reality instead of spirit.
I went and kissed your photograph instead
and tears were in my eyes."
- These are like I'm in
love with you letters.
- Yeah, and they didn't just
write letters to each other,
they also spent hours on the phone,
and allegedly ended every call with...
- [Both] (speaking foreign language)
- [Nikki] Which means.
- Get the door bitch.
(laughs)
- No, it means I love you and I adore you.
It's very sweet.
- It is really sweet.
- They have very sweet
feelings towards each other.
So, it's pretty clear
Eleanor was into women,
at least this woman can confirm.
As for Franklin, he died in 1945.
And sadly, Eleanor and Hick's
relationship also ended.
We're not sure by how or why.
- It's not out of the
realm of possibility too
that they just like, drifted apart,
couldn't spend time
together, found other lovers?
- After Franklin died,
she joined the United
Nations General Assembly
after an appointment
from President Truman,
and several times during her life
she was voted World's Most Admired Woman.
So she was an honored and
admired lady, so again,
probably why she couldn't be
like, "I like boys and girls."
So we learned something new today
that they don't teach
you in the history books.
- I mean that's pretty cool.
There was like a powerful
queer woman running shit
and falling in love.
- In the White House.
- Yeah, years and years ago.
- Ladies have had sex with
each other in the White House.
- That's my favorite fact
about the White House.
(laughs)